i
[Música]
una feliz mañana este es un avance
informativo de france 24 mi nombre es
ángela gómez al menos 233 personas
fallecieron en canadá desde el viernes
pasado por la ola de calor hoy que
afecta a la columbia británica en la
última jornada a la temperatura se elevó
a niveles se recortó por tercer día
consecutivo alcanzando los 40 y 95
grados celsius en la localidad de lipton
y se espera que los decesos aumenten a
medida que las autoridades actualizan
sus reportes de calor extremo
el fenómeno se extiende hasta el
noroeste del pacífico en eeuu la región
que está acostumbrada a las lluvias
prolongadas vive consecuencias del
cambio climático por un sistema de alta
presión que no se ha movido
francia podría enfrentarse dentro de
poco a la cuarta ola de kobe 19 debido a
un resurgimiento de casos por la
variante delta que se encontró por
primera vez en india lo informó el
principal asesor científico del gobierno
francés
el profesor del jean françois del fas y
el experto aclaró que la vacunación
ayudaría a mitigar el efecto de esta
nueva ola de la pandemia que se espera
en el país para septiembre u octubre el
ministro de salud francés olivier gene
dijo esta semana que la variante cobit
delta cuya rápida propagación ha llevado
a algunos países a imponer restricciones
de viaje representa alrededor del 20 por
ciento de los casos en francia
y se cumplen seis meses desde la entrada
en vigor del break city y también vence
el plazo para que ciudadanos de la unión
europea soliciten el permiso para
quedarse a vivir en el reino unido- la
pandemia que marcó la salida no ha
permitido ver el impacto económico real
para los británicos que están divididos
por el problema del referendo en escocia
y por el protocolo de irlanda del norte-
vamos a londres con nuestra corresponsal
luisa pulido
estos primeros meses del break si han
estado bajo la sombra de la pandemia del
coi 19 cuyo efecto no ha permitido ver
el impacto real en la economía británica
aunque lo cierto es que las predicciones
de una catástrofe no se han visto
todavía lo que sí es cierto es el
impacto y la amenaza en la estabilidad y
la unión del reino unido- primero por la
posibilidad cada vez más tangible de un
segundo referendo de independencia en
escocia y segundo por el protocolo de
irlanda del norte esta región para
mantener la estabilidad política y el
acuerdo de paz de 1998 se encuentra del
mercado dentro del mercado único de la
unión europea lo que hace que enviar un
producto desde cualquier ciudad
británica a esa región es considerado un
tipo de exportación lo que por supuesto
está generando traumatismos entre tanto
la población sigue completamente
dividida
una encuesta reciente asegura que sólo
una de nueve personas cambiaría la
manera como voto
referendo del 2016
este 30 de junio se cumplen 30 años del
fin oficial del apartheid undíacomohoy
pero en 1991 llegó a su fin el sistema
político y social que permitió a la
minoría blanca de sudáfrica gobernar
durante 42 años el 17 de junio de 1991
las tres cámaras habían derogado la
última de las leyes que sostenían el
apartheid pero sólo hasta esta fecha
acabó la segregación racial es
sistemática en el país africano
y finalizamos hablando de fútbol ya se
conocen los ocho equipos que disputarán
los esperados cuartos de final de la
eurocopa después de la derrota de
alemania contra los británicos el
viernes bélgica se enfrentará a italia
mientras que suiza jugará contra españa
el sábado la república checa se medirá
contra dinamarca y ucrania ante
inglaterra
hasta que este avance informativo siga
con nosotros en france 24 y en france 24
punto com buenos días
[Música]